vor kurzem habe ich wieder angefangen
voll zu arbeiten nach der babypause da
war unser freundlichen der sonne
zweieinhalb monate alt und deswegen
werde ich ziemlich häufig gefragt wie
ich das gerade so hinkriege mit familie
und beruf naja ich krieg so hin wie
viele väter auch nämlich indem ich einen
partner zu hause habe es ist ja
heutzutage nichts besonderes mehr wenn
eine frau karriere macht aber wenn ein
mann zu hause bleibt und sich um die
kinder kümmert wird er entweder kritisch
beäugt kann das haben kinder oder wie
ein held gefeiert
für einmal so oder so mein mann und ich
sind nicht die norm die basiert zum
großen teil auf der idee dass mütter von
natur aus die besseren eltern sind und
dass sie eine besondere bindung zum kind
haben die väter so nicht haben im jahr
2020 ist man vielleicht genau zu sagen
das ist ja alles quatsch
geschlechterrollen sind gesellschaftlich
konstrukte naja geschlechterrollen sind
sicherlich gesellschaftlich und
kulturell geprägt aber das heißt ja
nicht zwingend dass es nicht auch einen
biologischen einfluss geben könnte
deswegen schauen wir uns heute mal die
biologie dieser vätern und müttern an
und beantworten die frage sind väter die
schlechteren mütter frauen und männer
sollen gleichberechtigt seien klar aber
das heißt nicht dass frauen und männer
gleich sein müssen und gerade in sachen
nachwuchs gibt es ja offensichtlich
biologische unterschiede zwischen frauen
und männern die sich auch auf die
beziehung zum kind auswirken könnten hat
diese besondere bindung zum kind die man
mütter nach sagt vielleicht eine grund
biologische basis oder wie ich lieber
sagen eine grund hämische eine frage der
hormone die schwangerschaft und auch die
zeit nach der geburt sind ja ein wahrer
hormon tritt ich will hier auf das
vielleicht berühmteste
schwangerschaftshormon eingehen nämlich
oxytocin oxytocin wird manchmal auch das
kuschelhormon genannt und ist
passenderweise ein sehr hübsches molekül
was ist zum lieblings molekül vieler
kuschlig chemiker macht was ist euer
lieblings molekül schreibt die
kommentare
wohlgemerkt ist oxytocin nicht nur ein
schwangerschaftshormon oder nur ein
kuschelhormon sowie alle hormone hat es
im körper viele verschiedene und
komplexe funktionen aber seine bedeutung
für die schwangerschaft die steckt doch
schon im namen denn oxytocin kommt aus
dem altgriechischen und heißt soviel wie
schnell geburt weil das die wehen
fördert also die kontraktion der
gebärmutter außerdem hilft oxytocin der
mutter bei der milchbildung und beim
stillen kommt es zu einer erhöhung des
oxytocin spiegels sowohl bei der mutter
als auch bei dem kind im moment des
stillen ist kann das zu regelrechten
glücksgefühlen führen und generell
stärkt oxytocin die bindung zwischen
mutter und kind gegen so eine chemische
bindung kommt der papa wohl kaum an oder
erstaunlicherweise schon der inzwischen
weiß man dass auch bei vätern das
kuschelhormon erhöht wird in dieser
studie aus dem jahr 2010 besuchten
forscher 80 zusammenleben der
elternpaare und bestimmt sind deren
oxytocin level anhand von blutproben
einmal direkt nach der geburt und einmal
sechs monate später zu beiden
zeitpunkten gab es keinen unterschied im
oxytocin spiegel zwischen müttern und
vätern das deutet darauf hin dass
oxytocin er mit dem verhalten zusammen
hängt also zum beispiel ausgeschüttet
wird wenn man mit dem kind spielt und
wenn der papa das macht kann er sich
eben auch seine ladung kuschelhormon
abholen
das war vor zehn jahren eine
überraschende erkenntnis dass hatte man
vorher gar nicht so vermutet das war
aber schon länger wusste ist dass väter
einen niedrigeren testosteronspiegel
haben als nicht väter oder segel männer
man musste nur nicht ob männer mit einem
niedrigen testosteronspiegel er vater
werden oder ob die vaterschaft den
testosteronspiegel sinkt diese studie
spricht für letzteres hier wurde eine
gehörte von über 600 philippinischen
männern untersucht das erste mal als die
männer im schnitt 26 jahre alt waren
das zweite mal vier jahre später also im
klassischen zeitraum zum heiraten und
oder kinder krieg ergebnisse waren sehr
interessant erster
männer die zum ersten test zeitpunkt zu
wahren und von vornherein einen hohen
testosteronspiegel hatten hatten eine
erhöhte wahrscheinlichkeit vier jahre
später also am zweiten test zeitpunkt
entweder verheiratet oder vater zu sein
doch spannender weise führte eine feste
beziehung zu einem absenken des
testosteronspiegels aber besonders tief
waren die testosteron spiegel bei
frischen vätern
außerdem galt je mehr zeit die väter mit
ihren babys verbrachten desto tiefer
waren auch ihre testosteron level also
auch männer erfahren hormonelle
veränderungen durch ein baby auch ohne
schwangerschaft und stillen und nicht so
dass neurologisch fürsorglich ändert
sich denn auch das gehirn durch eine
elternschaft in dieser studie wurden 41
paare aus vätern und müttern sowie 48
homosexuelle paare aus zwei feldern
untersucht man schaute sich alles
mögliche an das verhalten der eltern
oxytocin spiegel und hirn scans einen
oxytocin messungen kam das gleiche raus
wie bei der studie vorhin also die
oxytocin level waren bei allen eltern
ähnlich egal ob vater oder mutter und
egal ob schwul oder hetero aber
besonders interessant waren die hier in
scans dazu legt man die
studienteilnehmer in den scanner und
zeigt sie ihnen videos von typischen
eltern kind interaktionen dabei waren
jetzt videos von den teilnehmern selbst
mit ihren kindern und auch videos von
anderen eltern mit ihren kleinkindern
als kontrolle gab es doch ein video von
den teilnehmern bei einer alltäglichen
tätigkeit ohne kind also zum beispiel
beim geschirrspülen während die
teilnehmer diese videos schauten
zeichnete der scanner den
sauerstoffverbrauch im gehirn auf um
festzustellen welche hier in regionen
besonders aktiv werden beim beobachten
dieser eltern kind interaktion
zunächst fand man heraus dass dieses
beobachten von eltern kind interaktionen
ein ganz bestimmtes netzwerk von
hirnregionen aktiviert das besonders für
emotions verarbeitung zuständig ist dazu
gehören zum beispiel die amygdala die
insula und
singuläre cortex dieses netzwerk war bei
allen eltern aktiviert egal ob schwul
oder hetero und unabhängig davon wie
viel zeit sie mit ihren kindern
verbrachten aber wenn man sich die
ergebnisse genauer anschaut sieht man
dass es für bestimmte hirnregionen doch
ein unterschied gab bei den hetero paare
beobachtete man bei den müttern eine
stärkere aktivierung der amygdala als
bei den vätern der mitte da ist die hier
in regionen die unter anderem für ein
belohnungs gefühl und für emotionales
lernen verantwortlich ist das ist sehr
interessant denn bei allen untersuchten
hetero paaren war auch die mutter
diejenige die sich vorrangig um das kind
kümmert also eine klassische
rollenverteilung doch besonders spannend
waren die ich hier in scans der schwulen
väter paare denn auch hier beobachtete
man eine verstärkte aktivierung der
amygdala und zwar bei dem vater der mehr
zeit mit dem kind verbrachte
je mehr stunden pro woche ein elternteil
mit dem kind verbrachte desto stärker
war die verknüpfung zwischen der
amygdala und einer weiteren hirnregion
die unter anderem mit gesichtserkennung
und empathie in verbindung steht diese
studien unterstützen folgende hypothese
seine hormone oder deine neurologie
geben nicht vor wie gut du dich und dein
kind kümmert sondern wenn du dich um
dein kind kümmert stellen sich auch
deine hormone und dein gehirn darauf ein
aber heißt das wir unterscheiden uns da
grundlegend von tieren ein tierischer
vergleich also wir wissen ja pinguine
zum beispiel die texte sich ja immer ab
mit blüten und futter holen die kümmern
sich komplett gleichberechtigt und ihre
babys aber die sind ja keine pinguine
leider die welt wäre ein besserer ort
jedenfalls ich meine säugetiere also bei
anderen säugetieren scheint es ja die
regel zu sein dass die mutter für den
nachwuchs zuständig ist zumindest ist
das der eindruck den man gewinnt wenn
man ein tier doppelschau
ja immer die mama die da alleine den
laden schmeißt tatsächlich ist
väterliche fürsorge unter den
säugetieren nicht die regel aber zu den
ausnahmen die die regel bestätigen
gehören auch unsere nächsten verwandten
ist das ist der thalia regeln dozentin
für anthropologie und prima theologie in
new york wir haben sie angezeigt weil
sie verschiedene arten von affen
beobachtet hat manche dieser arten leben
in ähnlichen beziehungen wie die meisten
menschen also in mehr oder weniger
monogamen beziehungen zwischen weibchen
und männchen die anthropologen können
sich gut vorstellen dass bei den frühen
menschen ist auch komplett gemeinsam als
mir bewusst wie karim den nächsten
auftritt
grosselfinger glücklich die schulter
wie kurz bewegen wollen
lifestyle events aus anthropologischer
sicht sind unsere geschlechterrollen in
der kindeserziehung also stark kulturell
geprägt und kulturell enorm ändern sich
ständig und das nicht nur über
jahrtausende die neuen väter
da tut sich ja einiges und die männer
machen das damit diese idee naja wir
gehen nur arbeiten frauen bleiben zu
hause
die frauen aus um auch nicht das ist
andreas kost entwicklungspsychologe und
väter forscher in hannover er hält wenig
von der idee dass frauen irgendwie von
natur aus besser sein in der
kindeserziehung diese vorstellung
basieren nicht nur auf veralteten
familienmodellen sondern auch auf
inzwischen überholten wissenschaftlichen
meinungen also heute veraltete position
auch was hat sich analyse beispielsweise
dem mann gesagt haben der vater ist der
dritte im bunde es gibt eine mutter kind
gerade oder kommt der vater als dritter
hinzu
der wird dann das außen repräsentieren
holt objekte rein und nach und nach wenn
das kind älter wird spielte auch eine
rolle dass sind aber ganz klar mythen
das ist eine psychologische unsinn
das alles zu ändern auf diesen ganzen
ebenen an die alten theorien ein
bisschen auszubremsen das braucht
einfach zeit
diese alten theorien werden heute vor
allem durch die praxis widerlegt wenn
wir gucken auch und wie sich später an
kinder binden wenn wir gucken was väter
mit kindern machen ob sie kinder
bespaßen können ob sie kinder pflegen
können ob sie erzielen können und sie
mit ihnen spielen können ob sie
vertrauen entwickeln
ob die emotionen entwickeln nähe liebe
dann sehen wir eigentlich wenn wir es
wirklich vergleichbar machen den vätern
haben dazu geben wir keine unterschiede
manche väter sind vielleicht noch
ungeübt haben keine vorbilder glauben
dass sie das können müssen das bisschen
erst ausprobieren
aber natürlich gibt es die vater kind
bin doch natürlich gern fährt genauso
gut trösten
auch väter können mit kleinen kindern
umgehen können sich anpassen können
bickel in den vordergrund spielen weder
können der ansprache reden übrigens
ansprache ist das hier im test hier ein
kleines bisschen und männer können das
natürlich auch dass ich ein kleines kind
ist ja eigentlich anders rum
so muss das sein oder egal aber selbst
wenn man sich als paar am liebsten alles
möglichst gerecht aufteilen würde gibt
es doch so ein paar fallen die sich
manche paare gewissermaßen selbst legen
stichwort gate kipping viele eltern
reden von gate kipping oft kombiniert
mit dem orden mütterlich natürliches
geld kipping
gemeint ist damit dass der fall den
mutter quasi die torhüterin ist die
quasi den zugang des vaters zum kind
reguliert also musste das tor auf macht
und zu ihrem vater sagt ach machst du
das doch auch du kannst doch mit dem
kind ebenso gut spielen dann macht der
vater dass wenn die mutter das tor zu
hält und da hatte ich kann das besser
sache dann tut der vater sich vielleicht
schwer und macht es nicht beispiel das
kind möchte nie ins bett riesen eck das
kind ins bett zu bringen die mama macht
es öfter hat irgendwann so die tricks
raus und wir zum guten 8 profi der papa
trägt das kind nicht so oft ins bett und
wenn erst mal versucht dauert direkt
dreimal so lang und so kann es zu einem
teufelskreis kommen nämlich der papa
bringt das kind nie zu bett weil er es
nicht so gut kann er kann es aber nicht
so gut weil das nie macht und so können
sich eben ungleiche verteilung
einschleichen selbst wenn man das als
paar gar nicht so geplant hat also wenn
dann unterschiede deutlich werden dass
glaube ich klug dass gerade der ist mir
macht das nicht so gut kann aber damit
das kind sieht ja ist ganz normal
auch die mama oder auch darüber kann ich
sprit bringen ähnlich wie beim
hormonspiegel vorhin oder bei der
genaktivität hängt es auch hier davon ab
wer wie viel zeit mit dem kind verbringt
und je weniger unterschiede ist da gibt
zwischen mutter und vater desto
ausgeglichener sind auch die
geschlechterrollen von der wissenschaft
zur praxis es gibt also anthropologische
psychologische neurologische und
endokrinologische hinweise darauf dass
mütter nicht von natur aus bessere
eltern sind als väter dieses wissen kann
eltern fahren zumindest im kopf der
freiheit verschaffen um die jetzt junge
so zu gestalten wie man wirklich möchte
er sei es jetzt hauptsächlich mama oder
hauptsächlich papa oder beide möglichst
ausgeglichen wissenschaftlich spricht
viel dafür dass jede variation der
aufteilung gut ist solange man ein guter
elternteil sein will aber
gesellschaftlich gibt es für diese
entscheidungsfreiheit noch einige hürden
vor allem für alle die ein weniger
klassische familienmodell bevorzugen ich
will auf all diese hürden hier noch
eingehen weil ich die momentan besonders
wichtig finde frauen arbeiten im schnitt
häufiger in schlechter bezahlten berufen
oder schlechter bezahlten branchen also
typisches beispiel männlich erste
weibliche krankenpflegerinnen außerdem
arbeiten frauen öfter in teilzeit und
sie unterbrechen ihre arbeit länger eben
wegen der kindererziehung und teilzeit
geringfügige arbeit und längere
unterbrechungen für nicht immer zu
insgesamt weniger arbeitsstunden sondern
gehen auch mit einem niedrigeren
stundenlohn einher
das sind übrigens die hauptgründe für
den gender pay gap also auf den
unbereinigten gender pay gap also die
hauptgründe warum frauen im schnitt
weniger verdienen als männer und hier
gibt es auch gewisse teufelskreise doch
nehme jetzt mal ein durchschnitts paar
von heute bei dem der mann mehr verdient
als die frau und dieses paar entscheidet
sich jetzt für ein kind und dafür dass
ein elternteil zu hause bei dem kind
bleiben sollte oder zumindest viel zeit
verbringen sollte wie teilen sie sich
jetzt auf rein wirtschaftlich betrachtet
ist nur eine sache sinnvoll nämlich dass
der mann der mehr verdient nicht weniger
arbeitet sondern die frau die er weniger
verdient
man kann sich natürlich frei andersrum
entscheiden aber das muss man sich erst
mal leisten können das heißt der bahn
geht weiter arbeiten er kann weiter
berufs und betriebserfahrungen sammeln
kann auch eine gehaltserhöhung oder eine
beförderung hinarbeiten die frau nicht
folge die lohnlücke zwischen den beiden
wird in zukunft größer das heißt
unterschiedliche ausgangssituationen
reproduzieren unterschiede beim zweiten
kind wird die frau schon wieder oder
erst recht zu hause bleiben und falls
man so ein familienmodell eigentlich gar
nicht möchte kann man aus finanziellen
gründen trotzdem drin stecken bleiben
doch frauen entscheiden sich nun einmal
häufiger für jobs oder branchen die
schlechter bezahlt sind
manche finden daher man sollte frauen im
bauern mehr typisch männliche jobs zu
verfolgen da bin ich einerseits schon
dabei
ich denke aber nicht dass das
langfristig und flächendeckend aufgehen
würde
denn wenn weniger frauen typische
frauenberufe machen
dann musste jemand anderes machen denn
wir sehen jetzt gerade in der groner
diese sehr deutlich dass viele der
typischen frauen jobs extrem wichtige
systemrelevante jobs sind und wie sehen
leider gerade auch dass diese
systemrelevanten berufe bis auf wenige
ausnahmen schlecht bezahlt sind und das
ist nicht in ordnung
egal ob diese jobs von männern oder
frauen ausgeführt werden also ich finde
langfristig geht diese ungerechtigkeit
über gender fragen hinaus da es momentan
der frauenanteil in diesen berufen recht
hoch ist gehe ich davon aus dass nicht
nur der gender pay gap sich deutlich
verkleinern würde sondern auch dass
unsere geschlechterrollen in der
erziehung aufbrechen könnten wenn man
nur systemrelevante berufe angemessen
bezahlen würde
man kann nur hoffen dass diese einsicht
eine der wenigen positiven folgen dieser
krise sein könnte
wie sieht es bei euch aus wie ist die
rollenverteilung bei euren eltern und
falls eltern hier zuschauen wie handhabt
ihr das habt ihr auch gatekeeper
probleme schreibt gerne in die
kommentare und wenn ihr dieses video
interessant findet dann kann ich euch
dieses video von frank und die frage
empfehlen
das ist teil der
mehrteiligen serie bin ich bereit für
ein kind und in dieser folge ging es
passenderweise um die vaterrolle bei
während den eltern verlege ich euch hier
und ident kannst du jetzt noch ein
ziemlich coole sounds münzfreunde der
sonne
ich habe erfahren dass ich dieses jahr
den heinz oberhummer award bekommen
eventuell seid jetzt jung um heinz
oberhummer zu kennen er war
österreichischer physiker und eine der
coolsten und wichtigsten
wissenschaftskommunikatoren nach seinem
tod wurde der heinz oberhummer award ins
leben gerufen um sein wirken und gute
wissenschaftskommunikation weiterleben
zu lassen und ich fühle mich unglaublich
dankbar und geehrt und möchte auf diesem
weg nur danke sagen an alle die
großzügigen menschen die diese
entscheidung getroffen haben
dank und grüße nach wien hier kommt ihr
wie gesagt zum video von die frage oder
zu einem ausführlichen video zum gender
pay gap ich bin auch noch auf twitter
app instagram ansonsten sehen wir uns in
zwei wochen bis dahin freunde der sonne
bleibt sicher